bonsoir mardi 22 décembre bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres de cette édition
dans cinq ans la france comptera un
million de personnes âgées
supplémentaire de plus de 75 ans un défi
se pose celui de retarder la dépendance
pour vivre plus longtemps chez soi dans
les yvelines plusieurs solutions
existent pour y parvenir le département
d'ailleurs a créé récemment avec les
hauts-de-seine une agence dédiée à
l'autonomie on en parle avec notre
invité
c'est un chantier qui vient de s'achever
sur la rd 191 hauteur des mesnuls le
département à replanter 146 tille le
long de cette route là où trônaient
d'autres tilleuls bicentenaire les
arbres avaient été abattus car infectés
par un parasite il représentait un
danger pour les véhicules et avec les
confinements cette année ils sont
revenus sur les tables des yvelinois les
jeux de société ont de nouveau la cote
en 2020 les ventes ont bondi focus à la
fin de ce journal
mais avant de développer ces titres nous
vous parlions il ya quelques semaines de
ce scandale sanitaire révélé à chez atos
aux clayes sous bois et l'émission
complément d'enquêté révéler des cas de
cancer rare du cerveau développé par des
anciens salariés et d'autres toujours en
poste entre 2015 et 2019 sept cas ont
été observés
la question se pose alors les ondes
électromagnétiques présentes sur le site
de l'entreprise spécialisée dans les
services informatiques serait tel
responsable des investigations sont en
cours et le maire d éclat sous bois à
philippe guiguen réagi au micro
d'eléonore sinoquet
[Musique]
je n'avais pas connaissance de cette
situation d' atos avant que je sois à la
mer par contre j'en ai eu connaissance
effectivement dès que j'ai pris mes
fonctions et c'est pour cela que dès le
mois de septembre
j'ai rencontré l'entreprise atos à ce
sujet je ne reproche absolument rien
atos
il y a eu une transparence de la part d'
atos vis-à-vis de nous il ya
malheureusement des cas dramatiques qui
sont vécues dans cette entreprise je
pense que les mesures et les aces qui
s'appelle le gast qui est à l'heure
actuelle mise en place au travers de
cette société bah donneront les
donnerons les conclusions mais moi je
n'ai absolument pas juger atos ça ne
peut pas se traiter comme ça entre ma
faute ou pas ou pas ma faute je pense
qu' ils sont en train de prendre toutes
les mesures pour connaître l'origine de
ces cancers si l'origine est une origine
du de cette société ou pas moi je ne
peux absolument pas me provoque me
prononcer sur ce sur ce sujet ma
position elle est claire vis-à-vis la
tôt c'est à dire une autre une
transparence sur ce qui s'est passé sur
le site ce qu'ils ont et aussi nous
avons saisi la rs madame le maire
précédent l'avait saisi également mais
je les ai de nouveau eu en télévisuelle
cette semaine pour avoir des mesures sur
l'environnement au niveau de la de la
commune des clayes-sous-bois de manière
à la également avoir des informations
factuelles pour la population dans
l'actualité également ses toutes
dernières données concernant le tourisme
au premier semestre 2001 la région
ile-de-france a accusé 14 millions de
visiteurs en moins d'après une étude de
l'insee et des chiffres qui s'explique
assez facilement avec une crise
sanitaire qui a fait baisser les voyages
de tourisme en france
le recul se ressent surtout dans les
nuitées hôtelières -70% sur les six
premiers mois de l'année
l'insee estime à 6 milliards d'euros le
manque à gagner suite à la baisse du
nombre de touristes
et vieillir dignement c'est un enjeu de
société et qui a pris occupent de plus
en plus selon un dernier sondage ifop
qui date de 2010 9 85% des français
souhaitent vieillir à domicile on parle
de cette thématique avec mon invité en
visioconférence asmae shoota bonsoir
bonsoir et directrice des projets pour
les projets autonomie pour le
département des yvelines alors le
département justement des yvelines a
lancé avec les hauts-de-seine une agence
dédiée à l'autonomie on va en parler
dans un instant mais déjà quelles sont
les possibilités en matière d'autonomie
si on met le curseur sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines ont fait le
point avec mélanie poké aujourd'hui plus
de 9000 à saint quentinois ont 75 ans et
plus alors si le territoire reste moins
marquée par le vieillissement de sa
population que le reste de la france
les études réalisées par l'institut de
promotion de la santé de saint quentin
en yvelines note une hausse de l' indice
de vieillissement l'agglomération
propose bien sûr des services elle la
plupart est rassemblé dans un site lemay
renter à magny les hameaux d accueil de
jour pour personnes en situation de
handicap vieillissantes ou atteintes
d'une pathologie cognitif de tel qu'un
alzheimer on va avoir également sur
place le service de soins infirmiers à
domicile qui va réaliser au domicile des
personnes en perte d'autonomie des soins
de confort et d'hygiène
on va également y trouver une équipe
spécialisée alzheimer qui vint au
domicile depuis 2015 il existe aussi une
plateforme aux d'avis elle permet
d'accompagner les personnes âgées et les
aidants familiaux à trouver
et bon service d aide à domicile elle
propose aussi des ateliers actuellement
aux visions autour de différentes
thématiques
on peut aussi noter sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
la présence de l'entreprise blue line
est un basé à elancourt
la société propose notamment une
plateforme de téléassistance et un
bouton d'appel 24 heures sur 24 afin de
lutter contre l'isolément des personnes
âgées
on a dans nos partenaires par exemple
les autonomies planeur qui est une
équipe qui se déplace sur directement
auprès du domicile de ces personnes
âgées et qui va coordonner ce qui se
passe donc entre une plateforme à
distance des objets qui nous permet
d'être connecté et après une équipe qui
va être sur place on a tout un continuum
en 2019 plus de 90% des seigneurs de 75
ans et plus vivent est encore à leur
domicile en france est avec moi je leurs
appels en visioconférence à semer shoota
directrice des projets autonomie au
département des yvelines les yvelines
avec les hauts-de-seine ont annoncé lors
du dernier salon hit onomie c'était aux
mureaux en octobre dernier la création
d'une agence interdépartemental pour
l'autonomie on va la présenter dans un
instant déjà se chiffre à ce mail fouta
dans cinq ans la france comptera un
million de personnes âgées
supplémentaire de plus de 75 ans
l'autonomie ça veut dire que c'est l'une
des grandes thématiques du moment c'est
celle qui va aussi animé on va dire
l'actualité dans les prochaines années
oui et c'est devient inéluctable nous
allons nous l'avons constaté notamment
dans le cadre de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire une agence interdépartemental
de l'autonomie pour répondre à
l'aspiration massive est tout à fait
légitime de nos concitoyens de rester à
leur domicile de bien définir en
sécurité et c'est pour cette dans cet
objectif en fait mais j'estime que
partage plupart de la france elles
avaient ou de lavéra prix 85% au coin
c'est pour cette raison que le
département des ti been des autres ainsi
que la sociologie se sont regroupés pour
fonder ce groupement on a compris le
contexte justement pourquoi unir
les forces des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine on rappelle que les deux
départements à sont engagés depuis 2016
dans une stratégie de rassemblement de
rapprochement il ya même l'objectif on
parle de fusion il ya eu plusieurs
plusieurs compétences 1 qui ont été
mutualisés justement sur cette
thématique de l'autonomie pourquoi unir
les forces des deux départements
parce qu'ils sont là des dix ont déjà
les deux départements sont déjà engagés
dans des efforts de mutualisation tout à
fait important que ce soit dans le champ
de l'insertion des bénéficiaires du rsa
que ce soit dans le champ de la
construction des programmes immobiliers
que ce soit sur dans le domaine là on le
voit de l'aude de l'autonomie que ce
soit sur la prise en charge des
traumatismes de l'enfant au travers de
ce gip qui va prendre en charge en
charge les enfants de de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance qui sont une des compétences
des départements donc effectivement unir
ses efforts pour proposer ce qu'il y a
de mieux et travailler sur la
territorialisation des axes considère
c'est notre ambition
justement quelles sont les missions de
cette agence alors l'agent ce concours
départemental de l'automne nous pour
pouvoir atteindre cet objectif de
permettre de respecter le choix des
français c'est d'abord de proposer des
bouquets de services à travers une
plateforme de services
on sait le parcours du combattant que
constitue la recherche de l'information
de l'accès service de l'accès aux droits
de l'homme
de l'information au soit en situation de
dépendance ou pas d'ailleurs on peut
avoir tout à fait une 61 60 ans être en
situation et vivre avec un handicap
être une entreprise une association de
services à domicile soins infirmiers etc
on peut on peut au besoin d'information
et pour cela l'idée a été d'avoir un
guichet unique de l'information à
travers une plateforme téléphonique une
plateforme numérique mais aussi des
guichets de proximité physique en
partenariat avec les collectivités
territoriales et les points d'accès qui
sont d'ores et déjà présents sur le
territoire
donc ça c'est pour la première entité on
va parler de la deuxième qui est un hub
d'innovation pour justement réunir tous
les acteurs qui travaillent sur cette
thématique
aujourd'hui combien de personnes qui
sont accompagnés justement sur cette
thématique de l'autonomie dans les
yvelines alors plus de 2 alors on parle
de chiffres savais que le départ
les départements sont compétents sur le
champ des personnes âgées handicapées et
ça constitue approximativement côté
yvelinois peu près le coût 12 mille
bénéficiaires de l'apa l'allocation fait
recette j'ai de la prestation
compensation handicap et du côté et
hauts-de-seine approximativement entre
unis lé dinh il voilà pour la deuxième
entité tout à fait je revendique donc
cette finances publiques et qui va être
déposées en préfecture tout
prochainement qui a été approuvé par nos
conseillers départementaux scène et des
e bonds se descendent fermiers donc d'un
engagement fort
plébiscité par l'ensemble des acteurs et
par l'ensemble de nos élus et donc
s'applique comme je voulais dire cette
plateforme
et les faux nique nique aux côtés des
boucles service du cerveau pour contre
le lien leur rompre leur isolement
pour pouvoir proposer des systèmes de
téléalarme de téléassistance sécurisé
l'habitat mais pour pouvoir proposer des
dispositifs de prévention de la perte
d'autonomie ou encore proposer de
l'emploi puisque la des demandeurs
d'emploi dans le champ des médias de la
personne c'est important et l'autre
marmitons de cette agence est servi
plein axe août à l'effort est appuyé sur
le rhône ni ce que c'est
émerger un nouveau jour où l'innovation
la verte permet de faire émerger nous
des innovations servicielle voit la
condition est que dans l'habitat des
personnes aux cuisses et tous les
dispositifs donc vous perdez sur la fin
de votre réponse à ce match comme on a
bien compris que le numérique notamment
à les faire de plus en plus son entrée
dans les foyers notamment pour aider
dans cette thématique de l'autonomie
merci d'avoir été avec nous un as my
food & shoot à part dont je rappelle que
vous êtes directrice des projets
autonomie pour le département des
yvelines
le département des yvelines justement
dans la commune des mées nul cette fois
ci qui a replanté ces dernières semaines
146 tilleuls le long de la rd 191
il remplace désordre bicentenaire
infectés par un parasite qui
représentait un danger pour les
véhicules et le reportage sur le sujet
de patrick jacques de dixmude et de
michael et demi d'euros des mesnuls
connaît une seconde vie le département
dehimi mien de replanter en cette fin
d'année de jeunes arbres le long de la
rd 191
ils remplaceront les 75 tilleuls
bicentenaire a battu en urgence de 2018
à 2020 suite à l'apparition de
champignons parasites
nous avons procédé à la plantation de
sujet tout jeune tout beau plein de
vigueur et qui vont pour les années à
venir les décennies à venir pouvoir
permettre d'avoir une allée des tilleuls
comme au temps jadis pour replanter
c'est à bhl département gestionnaire de
cette route a choisi de regarder les
plans historique de 1836 les documents
prévoyait notamment d'implanter les
tilleuls selon les alignements double
aux abords du château
nous sommes dans un patrimoine
historique et il nous a été recommandé
fortement recommandé de pouvoir procéder
puisqu'il y avait replantation au plan
2836 et à partir de là on a gardé le
même alignement et le même espacement
entre chacun des sujets coût total de
l'opération 300000 euros chaque jour
près de 5000 véhicules circulent sur cet
axe
jusqu'en janvier 2021 une exposition
photos se tient dans le hall de la
résidence andré dunoyer de ségonzac à
guyancourt 140 étudiants et habite elle
est gérée par l'arpej une association de
résidences pour étudiants et jeunes qui
gère mille dix mille logements en france
l'exposition réalisée en partenariat
avec la maison de l'étudiant de
l'université versailles saint quentin
pour objectif de mettre l'art et la
culture au service de l'accompagnement
et du lien social et les photos ont
d'ailleurs été réalisés par les
étudiants avec l'aide et de yann date
scène photographe plasticien lors d'un
atelier à l'université le but de cette
exposition au micro d'eléonore sinoquet
cette exposition elle et elle a été fait
pour garder ce lien social avec les
étudiants qui sont un petit peu coupé on
va dire de l'extérieur par rapport à la
crise sanitaire la crise sociale l'idée
qu'on a eue c'était de mettre en place
cette exposition là tout en gardant les
distances de sécurité et tout en
respectant en fait les gestes barrière
avec les de confinement et les couvre
feux successifs nous avons forcément
passer cette année plus de temps chez
nous pour s'occuper les jeux de société
sont revenus sur les tables des
yvelinois dans les plus de 300 boutiques
spécialisées en france les ventes
on dit en 2020 alors le jeu de société
est il pour autant l'un des loisirs les
plus appréciés éléments de réponse avec
célia gars de 100 go les jeux de société
sont ils le loisir de sept années 2020
ils ont eu beaucoup de succès durant le
confinement dans cette partie voir
c'était vraiment le cas que vous avez
joué beaucoup j'étais assez oui pendant
le confinement on en a pas mal profité
avec les enfants on a quoi comme jeu on
a le match thurman la bouteille le
monopoly parce que vous avez même
cette année oui pour en essayer d'autres
comme fort boyard qui d'ailleurs est un
excellent jeu en pour passer du temps en
famille parce qu'il ya des jeux afin
d'aider mimi et des tests à faire donc
c'est sympa
vous le voyez beaucoup on joue aux jeux
de société je me rendais à présent dans
une boutique spécialisée pour parler des
succédanés
[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes avec reste des gens
vous êtes responsable de la boutique
tout faux police oui nous donner les
tendances des sept années 2020 pour
cette année 2010 est une année
particulière donc une année particulière
il lui a fallu qu'on joue à distance et
tout ça et donc il ya des jeux qui ont
qui ont vraiment exploser ça va être
tout ce qui les rend libre à établir des
jeux on peut partager un écran vous
permettre de jouer ensemble même si on
n'est pas à côté il ya aussi la
consolidation de tous les jeux de skate
jam dont une loque était un des
précurseurs alors tous ces jeux où on
essaye de rendre de résoudre une énigme
ensemble et puis il ya aussi tout ce
qu'on appelle les jeux coopératifs il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de jeux coopératifs
pour émerger cette année voilà un peu
les tendances de l'année
merci beaucoup aux christophe déjean et
nous allons nous rendre maintenant j'ai
dans l'éditeur de jeux de sociétés
implantées dans les yvelines
[Musique]
hélène barral bonjour bonjour vous êtes
donc aux fondatrices pdg d'exode game
donc c'est une maison d'édition qui a
été fondée en 2017 et qui est basé à
guyancourt
donc vous avez multiplié par 3 votre
chiffre d'affaires depuis la création
alors là c'est une année un peu
particulière c'est l'année la nique aux
ide
on l'appelle comme ça et ça n'a pas été
facile mais bon et on est toujours là et
on s'accroche
vous vous avez quand même vendu beaucoup
de jeux de société cette année puisque
avec le confinement on suppose que les
gens ont alors juste jouer premier
confinement en mars des gobies nahd a
subi sa toute première rupture ils
s'engagent à sa toute première rupture
depuis sa création donc c'était la
première fois que les boutiques m'a
appelé en urgence pour en avoir et il
est en train de subir sa deuxième
culture
donc voilà il repart en production
également donc c'était une bonne
nouvelle pour le jeu wii les ventes ont
été on était là par contre votre chiffre
d'affaires s'en est plutôt bien sorti
cette année
ouf comme toujours dans la stratégie qu
vite ça prend quand même aimé les jeux
de société ont été un peu moins
impactées à ce que beaucoup de gens
veulent jouer pendant les confinements
merci beaucoup et la lonaci à vue vous
l'aurez compris les jeux de société sont
donc bien le loisir de sept années 2020
moi je vais aller faire une petite
partie des geraci couarde sur vos tables
aussi mais pendant les repas de fête
c'est un incontournable le chocolat
averse à une enseigne mise sur des
produits haut de gamme
après avoir joué aux jeux de société si
aliaga de son go est allé dans un
atelier de création de chocolat regarder
bon beau et bio c'est la maxime qui
anime la maison blanche situé à
versailles les tablettes de chocolat
reprennent d'ailleurs le damier de la
cour de marbre du château une
originalité yvelinoise jusqu'à
l'emballage
le gérant a voulu habiller ses tablettes
en toile de jouy
c'est un peu l'équivalent du burberry
anglais si vous voulez c'est
tout le monde s'est un peu approprié
cette cette toile très baroque mais
c'est un marqueur assez fort ancré dans
la tradition dans une forme de
classicisme à la française et c'est
comme ça qu'on voulait aussi imaginer
maison blanche créé il ya bientôt deux
ans l'entreprise a une collection de 15
tablettes aux saveurs particulières
lavandin bergamote cardamome ou encore
géraniums l'année 2020 a été compliqué
pour cette jeune société
elle compte sur la période de noël pour
se rattraper 80 % du chiffre d'affaires
de l'année devraient être réalisés ces
prochaines semaines
c'est une période qui rattrapait toute
l'année qui a été catastrophique
et pour le coup elle était très très
bien rattraper le tout la gamme a eu un
beau coup beaucoup de succès dans tous
nos réseaux de distribution et donc bas
les produits ont été appréciées donc on
a on a décuplé les ventes et aujourd'hui
voilà le carnet de commandes est plein
en tout cas et la cadence s'accélère en
fabrication le chocolatier sort en ce
moment 1000 à 1600 tablette par jour au
lieu des 700 à 900 tablettes
habituellement vous êtes dans l'atelier
de production
les assister au coulage des tablettes
donc on a le
un moule en polycarbonate
avec l'intérieur qui
en relief de la tour de mare du château
de versailles et ont vaincu les
tablettes à l'intérieur des nouvelles
tablettes aux éclats de caramel au
beurre salé devrait voir le jour en 2021
pour refermer ce journal le monde du
cinéma français endeuillé claude
brasseur c'était un ce mardi à l'âge de
84 ans une centaine de films dans sa
carrière et deux césar pour le comédien
il était notamment connu du grand public
pour avoir interprété le père de vic
dans la boum ou plus récemment le rôle
de jackie dans la saga camping acteurs
sur les planches également en 2016
claude brasseur foulé la scène du
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir pour
interpréter georges clemenceau nous
l'avions rencontrée à cette occasion
il nous parlait de son amour pour le
théâtre tout notre bande quand on est
dehors conservatoire toutes nos demandes
on ne rêvait que de terre penchait pour
du tout faire du cinéma ça ne nous
intéressait pas c'est très amusant le
fils et ma mère fait un métier de
technicien de deux acteurs peuvent à
meerab le mans jouer la comédie
si c'est mal filmé et mal monté on a
l'air de deux cons voilà pour cette
disparition club racer qui est décédé ce
mardi à l'âge de 84 ans voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]